did you see that that's bullsh
it ain't nothing good to come out of
this party before we get in let's have a
talk right here because I want to set
you straight right here you're a bigger
person and I know you're shaking me
really upset I rent my house to pay my
mortgage
stop it stop it
stop stop it hey stop it it hurts do you
want to come in on that
she's coming she's in the moment how do
you feel attached can I talk to you
alone but why is everyone around us this
is [ __ ] I really
irritated right now
I'm a really good friend okay I'm a
really good friend yeah what you just
said I'm a really good friend that was
not malicious malicious when you sit
down somewhere I don't like sure I would
love for you without yes I feel like I'm
so late to my own party come on I came
here with the best intentions for your
new beginning
to give me only good energy why will
their friend they're like they're close
to be talking about somebody else and it
will be one of me it will be so close to
laws I'm not saying anything it's all
about loyalty so what like no I think
you do say something thank you when have
I ever looking at anything that I've
heard about you in life there's five
billion things I can look up and say
about you and your relationship and your
home and your husband and anything I
don't say that don't knock my building
don't knock my apartment stop that's
purple duck this party should be called
the new beatings party not the new
beginnings party because I'm getting a
mental beat down from Larsa
I wasn't with my husband since I was 21
years old okay I had to work very hard I
get it okay
okay whatever
all day all night
[Music]
all right
new beginnings new beginning New
Beginning sorry for interrupting
this is real Olive Branch
how long did it take you to find yellow
branch couple of hours calling like
calling different floors do you have an
olive branch like I mean like a real
Olive Branch I need a real Olive Branch
no you don't have an olive a real Olive
Branch please it's important something
important congratulations on your new
home thank you and you look great you
too I feel like when Adriana brings an
olive branch to a party it means she
wants you to erase your memory forget
everything she said to you forget
everything she's done to you no I accept
the Olive Branch but I still have a
memory and it takes me a minute to
forget all the blows you gave me
where do you find an Olive Branch
I didn't even know you can find them I
thought it was just a term we use
everyone
use
place you've got to get over it
you talked about me a week ago how are
you my friend talk [ __ ] about you yes
you did it's funny to you and it's not
that serious to me because it's a story
than that it goes deeper than that
it starts from New York it starts from
New York you and I stopped talking from
New York I just expected you would have
an opinion I don't want to say that you
shouldn't you know that's not that's not
what I said you don't stick up for
yourself so don't stick up for me it's
fine what do you mean I don't stick up
for myself stop these days stop silly
sorry first off can we please go have a
shot and have a good time I'm sorry to
say things I shouldn't have said I'm
sorry about that but you need to talk
about it I need to okay pay my mortgages
we're over it let's go have a drink
sorry too all right I am sorry are you
serious
I said I was sorry you said you were
sorry please never talk about my
accomplishments
needing to get a mortgage for my house
by renting in my house that's crazy can
we go have a shot
I feel at this point Elise is getting
pissed off because she doesn't really
know whether she has a mortgage or not
is having a mortgage bad is it a bad
thing you know I feel like a lot of rich
people have mortgages and it's okay
apparently according to Larissa I rent
out my house to pay my mortgage
she said that I she goes away shots
the beginning of hell
you gotta swallow the whole thing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]